[Music]
the sun would have to orbit the planet
this way
when the sun was up the entire planet of
Earth would experience daylight and when
the sun went down the Earth would fall
into nighttime
there would be no time zones and no
Seasons either the sun retained its
gigantic form as it was orbiting a flat
Earth it would burn down the entire
planet that's because of how close it
would get to us
[Applause]
on the other hand if the sun were much
smaller than it really is we'd freeze to
death we'd be getting only one third of
a regular-sized sun's energy and we
haven't even talked about this yet Flat
Earth disciples believe in some kind of
anti-moon that's responsible for these
if that was the case for a flat Earth
this is how those eclipses might look